we're going to release the chakras
starting at the top second row we gotta
hit up nothing I don't know what that
means no nothing it's the most popping
Club in LA dude everyone knows that I
have know the club's called nothing come
on man names are played out anyway I met
this dude at the weed shop he got me on
the list plus one tonight and we're
going bro I've got a focus man I can't
go out getting shit-faced
what if ami calls me for an emergency
audition and I'm hungover and I throw up
all over Tarantino then I'm okay
well I see Tarantino out all the time
dude so it's good to be social it's
called networking actors directors
producers they're all out shaking babies
and kissing dicks if I'm at a club and I
see a baby or anybody kissing a dick I'm
gonna kill myself you need to get laid
how long has it been
who cares not since he moved to LA huh
yeah because I'm focused on my dream
Rick bro I want you to succeed this is
your dream and he's like yeah I want to
keep living out here to eventually find
my dream it ain't in Iowa cornfield we
move to Hollywood let's live in
Hollywood it's a good point man
Tarantino's oh yes I do miss boobs you
deserve them two of them
[Music]
my boy put us on the list I thought you
said we were on the list okay I didn't
follow up or anything he's not
responding to any of my texts so that's
a good sign hey what's up man yo name
Rick markussi plus one it's a cool dance
all right I got a markussi no plus one
what oh you don't recognize them
[Music]
Gary's cows Oh Game of Thrones season 12
the final arc he played the Ravens dad
at the Battle of Gargamel there's only
six seasons of Game of Thrones just
don't worry this little guys an actor oh
yeah I'm on season 69 if I would
your mother now both you guys aren't
getting in oh no what do we do now
have a nice night you guys eat my
[Music]
season 69 because I was so funny
what a dick toy guy I think you came to
let in one more dude that's how I'm
saying it's like you're just standing in
front of a door that's all you're doing
there's no degree for that you know what
I mean like anybody can buy a clipboard
I can buy a clipboard you know I wasn't
given to you by a wizard it's not a
special thing like you dickless
stick oh hello babies oh
I'm going in tell him that I worked out
a while ago
I mean it's so hot wanted boobs I got
you eight-five a real just breathe and
slow that Gary gameplayer carry those
tacos were good right yeah you have any
more coke
why don't you come of course you don't
it's fine maybe get some more tuck it
wet so I can snort some taco meat I can
get this is my profile these are all
selfies yeah but I've different eyeliner
on in each one all right
that's to distract people from your lazy
eye riots they don't notice it
excuse me yeah that one's like weird so
he basically got me VIP afterwards and I
was like what do I look like a poor
person like poor people get VIP you know
I'm saying so I'm at this Butler
promoter who got me artist guest took me
to see Calvin Harris who was so dope
who is your favorite net Coachella this
year at Coachella yeah I didn't go you
don't like Coachella ah I was totally
gonna you I love Coachella I love
it serious i lobbed up all those babies
for you I know man I'm a little rusty
rustier than the 10-man suck in a
waterfalls dick okay just repeat this
really loudly
what Rick we have too much Molly
I guess just throw it away or you it's
like a homeless family Jerry why don't
you go grab a joint lighten up the mood
huh
[Music]
there's art and doors I don't patrol is
there scary
[Music]